♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THEY STARTED OFF
PRETTY FUNNY AND THEN GOT
GENUINELY HILARIOUS AND
INCISIVE,'S OF COURSE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" STATED THAT
B OF THE TIMES RECENTLY
DENOUNCED THEM AS A FAR RIGHT IN
FRONT MISINFORMATION SITE UNDER
THE GUISE OF SATIRE.
NO HUMOR ALLOWED.
TO THEIR EVERLASTING CREDIT,
THEY DID NOT TAKE THAT SITTING
DOWN BUT THEY WROTE BACK
ADMITTING THAT ACTUALLY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" CAN BE A
SOURCE OF DISINFORMATION PUT IN
THE NEST, WE'VE REMOVED THE
REFERENCE FROM THE BABYLON BEE
AND IMPOUNDED A CORRECTION.
WOW, SETH DILLON IS THE MAN THAT
MADE THAT HAPPEN AND BACK DOWN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THE CEO OF BABYLON BEE.
A SOFT, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
YOUR SITE, HOW IT GOT SO GREAT.
IT WAS GOOD, BUT THEN IT GOT
AMAZING.
BUT I DIDN'T REALIZE YOU COULD
GO OVER "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
GOOD FOR YOU, WHY DID YOU DO
THIS?
>> FIRST, THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME ON YOUR SHOW AND GIVING ME A
PLATFORM.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
SINCERELY.
>> Tucker: ANY TIME BUT THAT'S
WHAT WE DO.
>> YOU KNOW, WE CAN'T TAKE THIS
LAYING DOWN.
WE ACTUALLY -- WE WANT TO POKE
FUN AT "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THE PROBLEM IS, LIKE IT OR NOT,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS
CONSIDERED A RELIABLE SOURCE.
SO WHEN THE SOCIAL NETWORKS ARE
LOOKING TO DECIDE WHOSE SATIRE,
WHOSE INFORMATION, WHOSE -- THEY
LOOK TO CNN, THEY LOOK TO SNOPES
PAIRED WHEN THEY ARE MAKING THIS
MISCHARACTERIZATIONS, WE WANT TP
THINGS LIGHT, WE'VE GOT TO
SEND DEMAND LETTERS AND
THREATENED TO SUE.
OTHERWISE WE ARE GOING TO GET
THE BOOT FROM SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> Tucker: SO IT'S NOT JUST A
QUESTION OF HONOR, THIS IS NOT
JUST A DUAL BECAUSE THEY
INSULTED YOU, THIS IS A DIRECT
THREAT TO YOUR EXISTENCE TO YOUR
BUSINESS MODELS WHAT YOU ARE
SANE?
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
WE DEPEND ON THE SOCIAL NETWORK
FOR TRAFFIC TO OUR SITE.
IT'S MOST LIKELY A
SELF-PRESERVATION THING.
IT'S ABOUT SURVIVAL.
BY CALLING A DISINFORMATION
SITE, IT'S IN FACT THREATENING
TO SHUT YOU DOWN.
>> YES, AND I THINK THAT'S A
DELIBERATE STRATEGY.
LOOK, FAKE NEWS HAS BEEN A
CONCERN FOR SOCIAL NETWORKS FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS BUT
THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO FIND WAYS
TO FACT-CHECK, THE PLATFORM,
DEMONETIZE, AND DEEP BOOST
PEOPLE.
BUT THE LEGACY MEDIA IS TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT COMEDY
UNTIL COMEDIANS NEED TO LEAD THE
WAY, WE ARE THE FEW COMEDIANS
LEADING THE WAY.
WE ARE OUT AHEAD OF IT.
WE ARE MAKING FUN OF THE THINGS
THAT NEED TO BE MADE FUN OF.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS
INCREDIBLE DISDAIN FOR US, I
WOULD GUESS.
BY THE WAY THEY ARE TREATING US
AND WHY BY THE WAY THEY ARE
HANDLING THIS.
IT'S EXTREMELY IRONIC AS THEY
ARE USING THIS INFORMATION TO
SMEAR SOURCES, BUT BEYOND THAT
IT'S COMICALLY IRONIC.
BUT THEY KNOW BETTER.
>> Tucker: REALLY QUICK, DID
YOU EVER START A WAR ON DUMB UNE
PRETENSES?
>> EXCUSE ME QUESTION MIKE
>> Tucker: I JUST WANTED TO
CHECK.
WHEN YOU GUYS DO THAT -- IN THE
MEANTIME, CONGRATUL